[Music]
challenge in Nigeria and even the broad
Africa is insanely huge we have more
than 100 million Nigerians living in one
form of energy poverty or the other
we have more than 600 million Africans
electricity
our goal is simple to provide
electricity to the people that don't
have access to power
how can we build a system that could
allow people to access power quickly
efficiently and more importantly
affordable
[Music]
my name is
and I'm the CEO of ready
[Music]
is a climate company that provides claim
reliable and affordable electricity to
communities
the average person on the street is able
to access electricity when they need it
anytime and anywhere so the thinking was
that it has to be mobile enough that
people should be able to move it around
but simple enough that anybody can use
it and flexible enough that it can power
different devices at different times
[Music]
I went to Korea's kids I always wanted
to be excellent so I'm always coming for
the best in everything my mom is a
teacher and my dad is an MBA so
everybody just have to go to school they
are like all this educational background
and they kind of value education a lot
when I got to Toronto the different
experience was that there's power
everywhere it was like I was just amazed
at how I could I could get stuff done
it's basically like just get more
optimized because you can actually do
anything at any time I don't need to
worry about power and I could see my
productivity control
[Music]
that's your friends who sit trouble with
power I want you now I still have like I
have family members who struggle with
power I feel I'm obliged to do something
in that regard to giving my experience
so I was thinking through what's going
to be the best way to solve the problem
in the most affordable way and the most
efficient way
is Affordable that is mobile and also
that does both AC and DC power I must
think differently and I was obviously
operate differently so for us in ready
what we have to do was to innovate on
the business model side while also
Innovation on the technology side so the
technology build already capsule on the
business model provide the ready capsule
leveraging a rental model that allows
the average person to be able to access
it basically eliminating The Upfront
cost barrier that is associated with
assessing clean reliable and affordable
electricity
thank you
so like the design was done by one of my
friends the engineering was done by one
of my friends and they were just we're
just Scrappy just trying to guest of the
money that when they got it done for me
I was in Toronto then the guys Nigeria
would give you give also the feedback
they were seeing what we are doing
testing it and giving us psychology back
about okay change this model I just want
to remove this and all and yeah it was
um I looked back and I feel very
grateful and also you call it lucky to
be able to have those kind of people
because without them I don't think
already we were ready yesterday because
they basically laid all the foundation
to make it work
[Music]
already approach to solving problem of
the electricity sector in Nigeria is to
provide electricity to people
irrespective of socioeconomic background
[Music]
we observe that the critical challenge
is the financing part where people need
to pay a very expensive front cost to
even access the system so our goal is to
eliminate that often cost entirely by
using the room to use model that we have
so customer just go to the ready
ambassadors arrange the Council of
direct ambassadors the radio ambassadors
take the ready capsule from the ready
charge station and this Ambassador
cement increase their own quality of
living because they make money by
renting by becoming a ready ambassadors
because they rent the ready capsules
and they are not bounded by contracts
because what we observed was that the
other the most of the existing companies
they have to blind people by a contract
and all this kind of stuff
and that automatically just eliminate
the whole inequality around like who
assessed because at the end of the day
all you just need to access ready
capsule is just 50 cents and you're good
to go and which is the same money you
use in buying Coke and Gala or whatever
use it so like get ready to come so use
it to get energy to power your devices
power your phones by your laptops by
your TV
oh
I'm very socially driven with what I do
because for me it's more about the
people it's more about the impact
because I got to where I am today
because of a lot of amazing people and I
think the more you are very focused on
people one time to like make sure you
kind of increase the quality of life of
people I think it's a it's kind of um
it's an infinite game because at the end
of the year it's going to be you're
going to be solving it you're going to
get happiness I know they are going to
expose you to like more bigger problems
as a company we are continuously
evolving and we are still very new to
the game and we are still serving around
1500 000 businesses I think we can do we
think we can do two three million even
more
[Music]
I mean I'm kind of driven by impact so
my goal is to bring this file on
people's faces
you see a problem if you have the
resources or the capabilities to address
it throw yourself into it solve it bring
fun of people's choices and by default
you are happy
foreign